hi there steve kaufman here today i'm
going to talk about content content
is so important to language learning
finding good content
interesting content content at your
level to learn from where do we find
this content i'm not sure i want to toss
some ideas out there with you and i also
want to
show you a little bit of my library
where
over the years that i've been learning
languages i've been able to access
content a lot of it in the days before
the internet and the availability of of
content on the internet which has
dramatically increased the
quality and the quantity of content
that's available to us
i sometimes think that if all of the
people teaching languages in the world
were to spend their time and effort
creating content that would be a much
more useful
thing for them to do rather than trying
to teach the language teach the grammar
teach the rules drill and i should say
too that content
such as exists
easy readers readers whatever that's
full of pre-reading questions post
reading questions all of that forget it
just create content right now with my
turkish i'm up against the fact that
once i get through my mini stories and
who is she
from there to sort of genuine authentic
content is such a big distance i mean i
i know that because even though my
statistics statistics that link tell me
that i have whatever 2500 words
if i pull in an article from a newspaper
it's practically all blue so when people
say if you have a few thousand words you
got seventy percent of any content i
don't know where that comes from because
my experience is if i bring in
a newspaper article say it's mostly blue
unknown words
anyway before we get further into the
subject i want to give you a brief tour
of my library
first of all i warn you that my library
is messy
but some of the
books that have influenced me let's go
over here to my chinese section
you can't see that very well but there
are a number of readers there and that's
only a small part of the readers that i
went through when learning chinese i
spent so much time reading and listening
i mentioned these before you can't
really see them but the intermediate
reader
the uh you know uh
20 stories on chinese culture
etc what are some of the sort of
influential
content items for me i've got so many
cds of chinese seongshong or chinese
philosophy chinese history
here we have the first book that i ever
read in chinese
lotos youngza by lausa
now if all of this stuff if for every
item that i had
the digital text
and the audio were available then i
could learn them so much faster
because i'd have access to dictionaries
and ideally when we're dealing with
history for example maybe being able to
click through to some historical
references
um this was a book that influenced me i
read it all in german and it's about how
the brain learns i've referred to it
many times written by manfred spitzer
in my japanese learning this series from
nhk
on the history of the showa era
showa no kiroku i listened to it i don't
know how many times but i never had that
transcript for it if i had had the
digital transcript it would have been so
much more useful for me
uh you know swedish for example i have
i have listened to herman lindquist's
collection on swedish history that was a
major part of me taking my swedish from
a very limited level up to a more
advanced level this was another book
that i found in swedish which had
uh the audiobook with it about you know
rhetoric how to develop deliver speeches
um you know swedish books i always buy
books for which there are audiobooks
swedish is one of those languages for
which there's there are lots of
audiobooks russian is the same and then
on the other hand korean not so much so
i buy a book
in a bookstore here that doesn't look
very difficult but it's just a little
bit too difficult for me if only that
were available in a digital format with
an audiobook that would be awesome uh
here
uh just to show you i have you know uh
russian audio books this is the czech
series toki cesco minolosity that i
bought even though you can find it on
the internet french here are some
japanese audiobooks
uh you know the german
what have we got here are my swedish
audiobooks swedish here
and
french german spanish italian
from uh
il naratore
so lots of different things
uh i even met a greek publisher while i
was in
wherever portugal and he sent me this
lovely book which i would love to read
but it's just a little too difficult if
this were available in digital format
and even add to that with audio that
would be amazing here's my book in
chinese for those who want to read it in
chinese
so that's just a kind of a quick look at
my library
so that was a quick look at some of the
material that i have used in the past
for learning languages but we are of
course in a much better
period when it comes to
learning content
there's an abundance in certain
languages
like russian like swedish like maybe
spanish certainly english french there's
lots of material available
in other languages less so
at link we have in some languages
probably too much content maybe not all
of it is of good quality and maybe we
should be doing a better job and maybe
our members can help us in culling some
of the material that's not so good
however that's always subjective some
people may have already downloaded these
and have started studying them so we
can't just eliminate them we're looking
at how to present our content in a more
attractive way more like netflix and
that's going to be coming fairly soon
and we've got to look at better ways of
helping people find content of interest
but
in those languages where we have a lot
of content it's more a matter of helping
people find things but in say turkish
you know i'm going through who is she
it's all spoken in one female voice it's
very difficult to follow if you have two
people in a dialogue and you can can't
tell who's who because you need all the
help you can get in order to understand
something that's in a strange language
and in the case of turkish somewhat you
know a structure that i'm not used to
so
you know where do we get more content
for say turkish
turkish arabic persian greek
the languages that i've been doing
recently there is a lack of sort of that
next level of content and i don't know
what we're going to do i guess to some
extent i end up having to pay to have
the this kind of content created perhaps
there's people out there who have some
suggestions
uh maybe there are people out there who
can help us with content
finding more content i mean already we
have the ability to bring in videos with
subtitles from youtube
right however i can't find any turkish
movies or videos with subtitles to
import so that doesn't help me uh
one of the problems with bringing in
video you know movies per se is that
there is so many there's so many action
scenes where there are no words the
ideal scenario would be to have sort of
a
you know a
digest of the dialogue to study as a
lesson with audio and then to go and
enjoy the video or the audio the the
movie itself i mean there's many
different things that can be done
to to to take us along from that sort of
first stage
mini story stage who is she staged to
where we can really go after you know
authentic material and and so anybody
out there that has any ideas on where to
find such material what we can do
obviously if we can get people to have
simple dialogue simple conversations
with their friends or their spouses or
their kids even
and then transcribe it that kind of
material is not only lively
if it's spoken first and then
transcribed but typically those kinds of
casual conversations are going to use
uh higher frequency vocabulary so to my
mind that's an ideal kind of learning
material in the case of german for
example i came across
a series of interviews on different
radio stations in germany where they
talked about every subject under the sun
and that was a very important bridge for
me to take me to the next level of
difficulty and i think that
we need to focus more on coming up with
content that is interesting
accessible bearing in mind the dramatic
drop off of word frequency it's very
difficult to come up with stories at
that
mythical n plus one level of difficulty
you're gonna run into the fact that
the more interesting the material is
probably the greater the number of low
frequency words therefore they don't
repeat very often in a given text
and yet we want to get at that in order
to be constantly you know experiencing
the language reading in the language
listening in the language and and when i
think back of my
chinese learning experience like i only
showed you a small portion of the books
that i read and that i listen to it
takes a lot of content not just to pick
up the vocabulary but also to gradually
and ever so slowly have that you know
language start to seem natural to you so
and in order to stay on track to
continue learning
you know content is key and we i think
we i think we have to do and we are
going to do a better job at finding
content presenting the content helping
people find what we have in our
libraries and
maybe we should
hire a full-time person to do just that
maybe there's people out there that
would like to do that at any rate
content is essential
to a a sustained commitment to
learning a language and taking it up to
that
level of fluency that we all want to
achieve thank you for listening bye for
now
you